Millennials and gen Z are doe soy boys
for the most part and that's why they're
entitled that's why they cry and
complain that's why they vote for
ridiculous policy that makes no sense
that's why California is is now
proposing reparations despite the fact
California is a free state and has
always been a free state was admitted as
a free state and there and and the best
part is you only have to identify as
black you don't have to actually be it's
crazy isn't it so Rachel dolezal so
Rachel dolezal only she would qualify if
she lived there if she lived there okay
so if Rachel dolezal lived in San
Francisco for 13 years and had a family
member that was incarcerated due to the
War on Drugs she would qualify for the
five million dollars
none of it makes any sense these people
need to experience a cold winter where
someone comes in and says it's time to
chop wood or we freeze to death